- Kelly always wraps up the
show with something cool
from social media to bring you a smile.
Now it's my turn.
This is What I'm Liking.
(dramatic music)
(audience clapping)
Lots of little kids are scared
of going in for a haircut,
but it's always been an
especially terrifying experience
for six year-old Jackson.
Jackson is autistic and
usually his mum Laquista
brings headphones and snacks
to keep him distracted during cuts.
Now, one day Laquista forgot
to bring headphones or food.
So when she got to the
barber, she had no idea
if Jackson could handle
sitting in the chair.
That's when their barber Ree,
masterfully took control.
By the end, Jackson was
having a grand whole time.
Take a look.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
Let's say hello to Laquista Jackson
and their miracle worker, barber Ree.
(audience clapping)
Wow, hey, how are you guys?
What, that day had already been,
especially challenging
before getting to Ree, right?
How was that?
- Right there, so the day
started out just really bad.
We woke up late that day
and got caught in traffic.
So I forgot his headphones,
we didn't have time for lunch.
So by the time we got to the shop,
everybody was already kinda anxious.
And so my oldest son, he
goes in to get his haircut
and now it's Jackson's turn
and he absolutely refused
to sit in the seat.
So Ree is trying to put the cape on him
and he's blocking everything.
And so Ree looks at me
and she's like, I got you,
in her little calm voice.
- I love that.
- And I just sat back and
I'm like, you know what?
She's never gonna be able to cut his hair.
But I peep out of the corner of my eye
and she's actually cutting his hair
while he's running around the shop.
- Wow.
- Ree is really been
heaven sent to our family,
she's built this great
relationship with Jackson
and he asked me, trust her.
So we thank her so much
and he actually looks forward
to getting his hair cut.
- That's amazing, I love that.
And Ree you say you were determined
to make a good day for Jackson.
What was that like?
I mean, what gave you the idea?
- Absolutely, I was determined.
My goal was to complete Jackson's haircut.
When they came into the shop,
I could tell they weren't
having a great day,
but I know my guy Jackson
loves games, he loves games.
So I noticed his shirt,
he had Mario on his shirt
and Mario on the sofa.
So I told him we had to
protect Mario on his shirt
because the Mario on the
sofa was gonna attack us
and to complete the haircut.
I felt like it would distract him.
So the haircut turned out
good, everything went great.
And I felt good, I felt accomplished
to see them leave out the shop happy.
- Oh my goodness, it is such
a great thing that you did.
And I'm like you guys as
you're posed right now.
Thank you.
Right, that's not all,
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen Makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show,
wants to celebrate those creating
fearlessly, just like you.
So they're giving you $1,000,
that's 500 for Ree and 500 for Laquista.
So congratulations
guys, thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Thank you,
- Say thank you Jack.
- Thank you.
- Thank you Bud, I love it.